but I do have to read one note from the
collider team for you I'm just gonna
read it in the team's words because I
don't want to take all this I might say
how much money would we need to pay you
to make a watchman season two oh my god
I wish that I had an idea for watchman
season two and I and I really wish that
there is going to be a watchman season
two I just we put it all on the field
for season one and every great idea we
had I was like what if we just put that
in season one versus oh let's let's
let's stick it away for later and so it
could there be a second season of
watchman I personally hope that there is
but I but I don't think it should exist
just because people like the first
season just because I'm curious about
classifications like I said like about
370 thousand dollars is the what was the
impetus behind changing the designation
of the show from a Drama Series to a
limited series um that that decision
actually happened well above my pay
grade I think that when we went and
pitched the show to HBO we said we're
just gonna do one season and then see
where we are and just so you know it's
more of a Fargo model or a true
detective model where if there were
other seasons of the show it would reset
it's not the continuing Adventures of
these characters and they were like cool
cool cool and then when the when the
series ended they were like are you
gonna do a second season and I was like
I don't have any ideas and they were
like oh so you meant what you said
before and so I think that because
there's only going to be one of them it
feels more appropriate to call it a
limited series than a drama series but
again I don't I I get consulted on these
decisions but I don't make them